all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts over morning coffee
um I have a special announcement guys I
am officially coffee free for 4
days bored do you guys even
understand now I know I've been coffee
free before but last time I was coffee
free I was kind of cheating okay I was
kind of cheating I was drinking chai tea
Tes in the
morning
now straight water now everyone in the
office thinks I'm going to
quit and I think that's fair because
every time I've done this I've quit but
this time
guys I think it's different now the
reason I decided to quit coffee I'll
tell you
what I have been wanting to lose 20 lbs
for years I've been try I've tried so
hard and I'm going to get into that
because a lot of you guys had question
questions not questions but I guess I
got a lot of messages like very
concerned about my thyroid issues I
mentioned last
video and I was debating if I wanted to
share more about this but sometimes I
share things and other people have gone
through the same thing so maybe maybe
someone else has had the same issue I
don't know okay but what was I talking
about okay
so I I met with a nutritionist the other
day because I've been trying to lose
this weight forever
and he told me you really have to reduce
300 calories a day like that's our goal
for he didn't even tell me to quit
coffee um because he said I I get like
such a light in my
eyes when I talk about he we don't have
to quit it but let's try to reduce it
and then I thought to myself I'm like
well 300 calories a
day that's really my coffee in the
morning and I'm like so you're saying
all I'd have to do is quit this coffee
maybe it'd be easier just to quit it
this was my thought process was I right
was I wrong I don't know um but this
gives me an excuse to talk about health
and what my personal I guess Journey has
been with health I hate saying the word
Journey it's kind of gay but whatever
so when I was a kid I was an athlete and
guys some of my earliest memories are
are in the gym
I remember being like seven years old
playing basketball I'm I'm not like some
of you people some of you people can
remember up to when you were like two
three four years
old not me really like I kind of have a
bad memory in
general I forget what I did a week ago
you know what I
mean um anyways
so um basically I have trained very
intense from the time I was 12
and I I because when I was 12 I started
travel volleyball now what's travel
volleyball I used to train and I did two
sports so travel volleyball was 2 and 1
half hour practices like four days a
week plus weekends you would have
tournaments you were there all day like
we would get there at like I don't know
7 in the morning and leave at like
sometimes we'd leave at 4:00 4: I and
and a lot of times these were out of
state so I would be
in Vegas one weekend I would be in
Colorado another weekend like just
playing and I didn't really mind like a
lot of people
um would say oh that sounds so horrible
no I loved it I loved Sports from the
time I was
12 um and I played two sports so not
only did I do that but I also played
basball basketball so um I would go I
would basically get out of school at
2:30 okay and that's why when they say
are you a traditional woman I'm like
lady when was I supposed to learn how to
cook now I actually can cook now
everybody everybody says Pearl can't
whatever I'm not saying I'm a chef but
I'm pretty decent all right so anyways I
um I would get out of school at like
3:00 let's just say then I would have to
wait an hour for for basketball practice
that would be at I think like 4:00 maybe
I'd get out of that at 600 I would have
to drive an hour from school to
volleyball 7:45 at night to 9:30
something like that I wouldn't get home
till like 11:
12 no we get I I get home at like 11:00
at night then I would have to do
homework if I wanted to now me when I
was younger um sports that was always my
f like I just loved it you know when I
when we lost in college in college I was
the same way
too I would
organize extra practices like um during
off season I would rent out the the
school
gym and I would get all the the chicks
that quit basically cuz the chicks that
were on the team there's only a couple
that wanted to torture themselves with
extra practice like I did um so I
couldn't get like six on six so what I
would do is I would get the other girls
um that like quit or like didn't play
the year before and I would organize my
own
practices I loved practice now mind you
this did hurt me in other areas of life
um
obviously when you do that
um you know when you're out of the house
that much nutrition was never at the top
of my priority but my whole life I could
kind of get away with it cuz I just ate
sorry I just worked out so much and this
really translated into my adult life um
I got kind of fat after college um I
made made it to like 210 lbs and I blew
up really quick because I was used to
working out like four hours a day
because in college I might not well
actually I did I did do basketball I ran
track I even did lacrosse for two weeks
in college but I graduate right um and I
just blow up like a balloon because
I mean my body's like you're not working
out you've been working out 4 hours a
day since you were 12 I I ran a marathon
I literally I I decided okay I just got
fat I was like 210 lbs embarrassing I
know and I ran a marathon to lose the
weight and I did um then and and I was
back to the same weight cuz i' basically
been the same weight since high school
give or take like five like sometimes
gain five 10 lbs but then I'd lose lose
it you know um anyway
so well except for that time I was 200
yeah
anyways what did I do next then I signed
back up and now I play semipro again now
semipro definitely is not as intense as
College college was very intense um like
guys I I picked my school
because they didn't follow the NCAA
guidelines I think they got in trouble
for it
later but like I I would come to
practice it would be a 2-hour practice I
would get there like 45 minutes early I
wanted to win a National Championship
then on top of that we would have lifts
so after practice we would lift like and
I remember deadlifting two plates this
was right like like two 45 lb plates I
would have a 25 pound like I'm still
pretty strong to this I'm not saying
that this is good I'm just saying I am
anyways so now I'm an
adult and as an adult you work
more and I realized just because maybe
my BMI was healthy I needed to kind of
look into my hormones and my breathing
and like there's okay since I was a
kid basically I
had this issue of I would be one of the
most in shaped women on my volleyball
teams like if we did the mile maybe not
burpees but if we did the mile I'd be
like second there there's one little
skinny chick named Francesca she she
would just beat everybody but I I would
be second in like the running test but I
would be so out of breath I would be
like like it would sound so terrible
like it didn't matter if I was in better
shape than them I could not breathe like
a normal person ever and I've gotten
this from the time I was young
um fast forward forward I find out I
like breathe through my mouth and I
think you're not supposed to do that
basically cuz I've always had terrible
allergies I went to the allergy doctor
they they poke you know the things on
your back they couldn't believe it they
were like how are you allergic to this
much stuff I'm like I don't know um I go
to these
like what do you call it functional
medicine do I went to one of those
they're like how do you live like this
I'm like I don't know I just
live um so basically I've been trying to
figure out what the problem is now I'm
sure working out from a super young
age probably didn't help and I eat I I
eat a lot better than I did when I was
younger cuz I remember eating like
cookies for
breakfast when I was a kid I I don't I
definitely don't do that anymore um but
I still found it like exceptionally hard
to lose weight um anyways so I find out
my my T3 levels are bad they're like low
not good um probably from years of no
cuz remember you know if you're working
out this much guys and you're doing
school and I was a decent student I was
decent so I'm not saying I didn't like I
was a distay Days by any means but I
never had a problem failing
classes well I did fail one in England
but that was that was cuz I didn't care
but anyways but when I was a kid just
like historically I didn't I never
really failed classes like
that but
but so you know I never really had the
like cdiac Rhythm or whatever because I
mean I had practiced till 10:00 at night
I mean when was I going to get
this plus I mean I I've TR like I don't
even know what it's
like not to travel like even when I was
a kid we would go on vacation for like a
month during the summer my parents would
take us
to whatever National Park they wanted to
show
us yeah
so this was my life anyway so
now I'm trying to quit coffee because I
do I I've had that habit since I was
like 22 it's such a shame because before
that I did not have that habit I had a
friend in college she showed me a
caramel macchiato it ruined my life
forever it ruined my life forever
because before then I never drank coffee
this chick showed me that I loved
caramel
coffee anyways um so I actually I
anyways so now on top of that the past 2
three years I've done this night show
and a lot of people was like pearls
leaving the manosphere
whatever I mean I don't know once you
get red pilled you can't UNG get
redpilled but I was like I'm just
stopping these goddamn night shows guys
I can't do them I can't like I would be
up
until 2 in the morning now I know you're
like Pearl why don't you just recruit
for them during the day do you know the
headaches that come up come with putting
these on I'm like no no I'm okay I'm
sorry
I
I just I don't I don't have it in me
anymore
but I thought about it I was like maybe
I kind of want to take a month off I'm
demonetized I'm like maybe you could
just relax because people have no idea
how long it's taken me to build what I
have now I know what you're thinking
Pearl you blew up overnight there's
people that have done this for 20
years I'm not saying there's not other
people that have also worked
hard but a lot of people didn't see the
year before I was on YouTube so I
started the show in
2021 I think maybe it I don't know it's
my first year in England but the year
before that I did so many reaction
videos guys I did like I have 10,000
videos on my channel I would wake up I
would do 10 reactions a
day I would do 10 and before that even
during it I was also managing like a Tik
Tok account I to a million followers
so I've always had like a broad variety
of
interests anyways point is this point is
this I may take a month off this is
really hard for me because I I don't
know if I'll do it I might not
but I have to figure out what I'm doing
with my life next and like where I want
to go because one regret that I have in
life is is that I have moved around a
lot a lot and I really wish I didn't do
that now I do think I had good reasons
for moving as much as I did now I know I
know you guys are like Pearl what what
good reasons could you I do think I had
good reasons typically when I moved it
was because I wanted to accomplish a
goal you know for
example I switched schools in college
because I wanted to win a National
Championship and I was like I want to go
where I could win a National
Championship I liked my first school way
better than my second school that I
trans I I mean the second School kind of
grew on me but the first school I I I
enjoyed way
more but I gave that up because I wanted
to win a National Championship now did I
no you know um I I lived in Milwaukee
for a couple years I really enjoyed that
and right when I was starting to enjoy
it I decided that I wanted to go on
YouTube and do the social media
thing so then I moved I moved back to my
parents
house and while I was there well I
actually I had this decision I was going
to do social media while pursuing
volleyball I missed volleyball guys it
was a part of me
like it was you know I just my dad would
always tell me there was more to life
than volleyball and he's right there
definitely is but I didn't see it back
then anyways so I moved from Milwaukee
to back to my parents house to and then
I was supposed to go to England for a
year but it got canceled so I was at my
parents house for a year then I go to
England because I'm trying to be a pro
athlete at the
time you know now I'm in a Crossroads
because what I found is that usually it
takes about it takes about two years to
really settle into a place it takes
about 2 years to really like have enough
friends friends and like build up those
relationships and it kind of stinks
having to start over now every time you
start over you learn how to do it
quicker but I've learned in life that
the grass really is Greiner where you
water it it really is like I I I think
always when I'm happiest it's when I've
been in one place for a prolonged period
of time when I'm moving around all the
time you have to start over you know and
even like I've lost contact with some
really awesome friends that I mean I
don't want to say lost contact it's not
like we're blocked or anything we're
still friends but I I don't speak to
some really awesome friends on a regular
basis because I moved I moved I mean
chick you're moving all the time
so part of me is just like well I could
just stay in England I don't mind it um
and you know I was on track to building
this content house in London L my idea
basically was I wanted to build a
Content house in London and I actually
wanted to add a school to it I get so
many people that want to come work for
me what if I said hey apply to my school
you can edit you can we'll teach you
what we know boom cheap labor
boom boom cheap labor boom it's like a
win-win you know we teach you what we
know hire the best people it's like a
job guaranteed if you pass these
certifications or something
now we're demonetized now we can reapply
after 3 months and I'm fairly confident
we can get back in it um based on what
I've spoken with my YouTube BR um what
costus me to get demonetized with saying
I can't say it cuz I'm on YouTube let's
just say it rhymes with Fanny but with a
t and that you can't say that one group
of people is dumber than another group
of people
so when I used that in a gender context
I guess YouTube didn't like that so that
is the official reason none of these TMZ
reaction channels they don't care and
it's so frustrating because they don't
care about what's true they don't care
they have their narrative so you know
all of these
guys are just going to say I was
demonetized for something I was not
demonetized
for whatever whatever you know do your
thing guys
um but back
to back to what I was saying
about the health stuff pardon me because
I've worked so incredibly hard the last
three years like I have worked my butt
off
um I kind of want to just take a month
off I really do I'm like I'm demonetized
anyway am I I might do I might just go
home for a month I don't
know and in that month I really want to
focus on getting my hormone levels more
normal
because the last couple of years no my
whole life I've really neglected that
and and apparently sorry back to the
health stuff I might have a tongue tie I
don't know cuz some people say I have a
tongue tie some people say I don't but I
guess the buto breathing stuff might
help me
um
with like it's all connected they say
like the hormone stuff so apparently
like because I breathe wrong that
affects like
everything and I've been eating a ton of
steak lately i' like I've heard steak
like fixes you so I was like let's eat
steak don't know if it's had the
overnight effect on I was hoping for but
we keep on keeping on so I don't know
that's that's my my health stuff I had
so many people text me they're like it
was almost like I was dying I'm like
guys I'm not dying I'm okay I know I was
kind of bummed out in that video I was
like I think I think I was pretty sad
cuz I mean and that's the thing Guys
YouTube can take away your livelihood
like that it's like you do I can't even
imagine sneo he did that for 10 years he
that man grinded
10 years YouTube said not today
I'm demonetized and I I thought
about all the work I
did but sorry back to the content houses
you know I want to basically start
content houses in each cities and I
wanted to have like four or five people
per
house um but you know now we're
obviously losing money every
month uh so that's going to going to
kind of slow that
down and then my question is do I want
to keep building this content house or
do I just want to say screw it go
home you know maybe I'll I'll keep you
know Christine on have her but it's like
one person do I want to keep signing
people I really liked the idea of a
houses I wanted to do it in all the
major cities I want to do it in like
Vegas Miami but once you realize how
difficult it is
to like start
these you're like I don't know maybe
it's just too much work maybe I'll just
do my stuff I don't know but let me know
what you guys think in the comments
because I really wanted to contrib I
really wanted to build the media company
that I wished I had growing up you know
cuz even the rightwing stuff is just
like still La La Land it's still like
you guys are living in the 1950s it's
not the 1950s anymore I'm not happy
about it but like this is the world
we're in you know
so I really wanted to contribute to like
making the media that I wished I had
growing up and I knew it couldn't just
be me so I thought well I'm obviously
killer at YouTube so I should sign
people you know and now the question is
do I want to get like I can move into
like a official and and I have the money
I can do it
um audacity Network building or do I
just want
to you know go home I don't know U but
let me know what you guys think in the
comments because I for a year I've been
saying I'm going to move and I really
didn't like London but now I'm like well
it's kind of growing on me they're kind
of classy people and then I have to
start
over I don't know I don't know let me
know what you guys think in the comments
um no I'm
not yeah some of you guys the comments
it was like I'm like I'm not dying I'm
just I think my hormones are off like
the video guys subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time